حان موعد فقرتنا التفاعليات تحدي الامثال
هي لعبه بددناها طبعا نذكركم منذ اسبوعين
تقريبا بين مراسلين عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
السعوديه وعماد العضايله من الاردن بما
انه اليوم مشغولين بالتاكيد احنا قاعدين
ننوع فاليوم الصرع نسائي
عقافته بلهجته المحليه فيرد المراسل الاخر
بالمرادف من ثقافته لهجته ايضا انا اليوم
مع راويه راح نمارس دور
الحكام لجنه الحكم نعمل على اشعال الاجواء
طبعا راويه راح تقوم بهالدور مع انه هذا
الطبيعي يعني
بالدم ربما نقرر منو اللي راح يفوز بنهايه
الفقره طبعا المنافسه اليوم مشاهدينا من
مصر والعراق ما بين مراسلتي صباح العربيه
ندى حجازي وزينب المشاط اهلا وسهلا فيكم
صبايا ليش مو واقفه على دجله يا زينب يلا
صباح الخير طيب خلينا نبدا اذا حرب
الامثال او هذا التحدي
مع مين مع زينب اول شيء تفضلي يا زينب
بدنا اياك تتحدي ندى وبدنا نشوف اذا ندى
قد التحدي ولا لا ارمي القفاز
يا راويه اني بالبدايه
منو اني راح افوز لانها على قوله ابو
المثل انه اني قلبي دكان والراويه والعادل
والمدى في مكان
والله شكلها فازت من اول من اول تبلش
ههه يلا خلينا نبلش امثال يا زينب تفضل
المثل الاول
اللي المثل الاول هو مثل عراقي كلش مشهور
يتحدث عن استحاله حدوث الشيء ويقول لكم
ابليس للجنه اها ندى عندك مقابله
والله يا زوزو انت صاحبتي بس انا يعني
هتغدى بيكي قبل ما تتعشي بيا بصراحه ههه
يلا احنا طبعا عندنا مقابله
فبنقول لو كانت الغله قد التبن كانت الحمى
حبه مرات الاب
يلا يا زينب اعطيها
بالعراق يتحدث عن الشخص اللي ما بيشوف في
عيوبه يقول لك لو قرد شاف اذانه كان حار
زمانه
حلو هذا عندنا ابو تهيا لي فيه اكيد ندى
عندها مرادفه يلا يا ندى شو عندك
احنا عندنا برضو نفس المثل لكن على الجمل
بقى بيقولوا الجمل ما بيشوفش عوجه رقبته
اه والله ما بيشوفش فعلا ما بيشوف طيب اخر
ما بعرف شو زعلنا مثال مثلا او مثلا
ضايلين يا زينب شو عندك
اني باعتباري ما احفظ
انا باعتباري اني كل واحد يوقف على الجهه
اللي انت واقفه عليها يا زينب لازم يمسك
الورقه يلا
عماد وانت ما يصير
فكلي على السين احنا عندنا مثلا لو حابه
تسمعي حدا يعني كلام فتقولين انه
احاكيك يا بنتي واسمعك انت
الحكي الك واسمعي يا جاره بالفلسطيني
البنت نقول لها ايه ايوه نقول لها ايه
احنا عندنا الموضوع يعني بيبقى شكله مختلف
شويه بنوقف في الشباك ونكلم كده حد نقول
له ايه الكلام ليكي واسمعي يا جاره
والله ندى مش قليل قوي على فكره هي كمان
عم بتغش من التلفون طيب خليني اتولى مصر
الان اروح ندى قولي اول مثل مصري ودي
لزينب ويمكن ما تردش عليك سريعا اهو يلا
شافت ولادها على الحيط قالت دالولي وملدوم
في خيط يا سلام
يلا قولي
ردي عليها طيب يا زينب
احنا عندنا
[ضحك]
احنا
يعني تشقلبت الطنجره ولقت غطاها عصفور كفل
زرزور واثنين هم طياره يلا
يا شيخ
كمان كمان مثل عندك اليوم امثارنا كلها من
الغابه قول يلا يلا يا ندى
طبعا عندنا
لما واحده تتجوز واحد مش مناسب لها خالص
عشان فلوسه بنقول ايه يا واخد القرد على
ماله يروح المال ويبقى القرد مظبوط
زينب العراقي
سيد علي منهم ههه
حلوه انا مش عارفه احكم بينكم بصراحه انا
شايف قوايا اقوياء كثير طيب ضايل اعطيهم
يلا هذا التحدي الاخير المثل يلا
الاخير
على الاخرين
لما بيعرفش يرقص بيقول الارض عوده عوده
شوف بالمصري قولي
لا مش هساعدك انا قولي انا حكم خدوم بصوت
ليغلبوكم ايوه خدوهم بصوت لا يغلبوكم
مثل بالمشابه احنا نقول احنا نقول طبق اه
احنا نقول طبل صوته عالي ومن جوا فارغ ما
شاء الله
انا بصراحه بقول تعادل تعادل
مع انه انا عادل تعادل طيب انا انا راح
تقبلون مني لان انا يعني مثلا اوكي النصف
العراقي ولكن الهواء مصري لا انا ده حجازي
زينب مو محاضره صح خلاص ندى حجازي انا
عندي ندى ندى ارمي نفسك في النيل عشان انت
فرحانه قوي يلا
زينب لو بعرف يعطيك العافيه شكرا زينب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات